please welcome Eva Marie Saint Goldie
Hawn Angelica Houston Whoopi Goldberg
and Tilda Swinton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the five of us standing before you
represent the 70 women who have been
honored to receive the Oscar for Best
Supporting Actress and tonight we're
here to welcome a new member to the
group and to personally help celebrate
the five extraordinarily gifted
actresses nominated this year in rare
instances then actress makes such an
impression and only a few brief scenes
that the energy of her work carries her
all the way to his seat at the Kodak
Theatre on Oscar night well that is what
you did Viola Davis
[Music]
in the film doubt we all watch not just
a studying talent command every moment
she's on screen but an unforgettable
portrayal of the porosity of a mother's
love for her child and you left us
wanting only more Viola Davis
congratulations
[Music]
when Penelope Cruz first blazes on
screen and Vicky Cristina Barcelona she
lets forth a dizzying combination of
Spanish and English and even if we don't
understand every word she's saying
literally emotionally we understand
absolutely everything uniting the wild
and the winning Penelope you show us
that beneath your beauty lies the soul
of a true comedian Phil estación is
finality
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not easy being a nun
take it from one who's been there and
back first of all your face never looks
thin you never get to wear pants and
your love interest is always off-screen
but in spite of this amy adams showed us
how a woman very new to the veil could
summon up the courage she didn't know
she had and place herself in the middle
of a deeply troubling moral mystery she
was compelling and moving without a
doubt bless you Amy
[Music]
there's a moment in Benjamin Button when
after traveling the world Brad Pitt
comes home to see his mother and we
realized that we've missed her as much
as he has and that is a true testament
to a really beautiful performance
taraji P Henson you reminded us that
love is unconditional timeless and
ageless and a really very special gift
to be treasured and so are you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nominated this year for her
compassionate and open-hearted
performance in the restaurant in which
she reminds us not only of the
effortless physical expertise of a real
working girl and the courage the
selflessness required of a dedicated
working mother and the Shia honest fact
that a stripper need never take off her
dignity with her clothes we honor you
Marisa Tomei
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this year the Academy salutes you all
and the Oscar goes to Penelope Cruz
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's not going to be 45 seconds I guess
right now has anybody ever found here
because I might be the first one thank
you so much to the Academy I want to
share this with my fellow nominees and
with the amazing and some all of actors
that I had the privilege to work with in
this movie Thank You woody for trusting
me with this beautiful character thank
you for having written over all these
years some of the greatest characters
for women and I cannot talk about great
female characters without thanking my
friend Pedro almodóvar for having made
me part of so many of his adventures
[Music]
thank you thank you big eyes Noonan
Fernando Trueba for giving me my first
two movies Thank You Harvey Weinstein I
want to dedicate this to my parents and
to my brother and sister to my friend
Robert Carlock who is not with us
anymore
and to everyone who has helped me from
the beginning and you all know who you
are and I thank you from my heart I I
grew up in a place called alcobendas
where this was not a very realistic
dream and I always the night of the
Academy Awards I stay up to watch the
show and and I always felt that this was
the this ceremony was a moment of unity
for the world because art in any form is
and has been and will always be our
universal language and we should do
everything we can everything we can to
protect its survival so I thank you so
much and I have to say something in
Spanish because everyone todos los que
d'espagne Austin come party end este
momento cameo is en tant que esto
también es de ellos se lo de decoy a
todos los actores mi Pais muchisimas
gracias thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]